sukh hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to slime
rancher now my objective for this one is
I am going to get that cat to explode no
matter what I for some reason in this
game have a very negative opinion about
cats which is not true cuz I love cats
matt has a banana Rambo in the house all
the time and while Matt's away you know
bananas been very nice and always tries
to get in my room and then immediately
immediately like if I'm not looking he
will - underneath my bed and just stay
there forever and at this point I'm just
like I don't care for do whatever you
want to do but I forgot that it's
nighttime actually you know what I'm
gonna play dangerously here because I'm
gonna go out at night because I've never
experienced a full night by myself in
this area I'm gonna pick up some rock
climbs if I can on the way to Mary you
please thank you let's get out of here
thank you please please kill her damn it
why oh why can't you do that to the
other like black goose the weird slimes
the anti slimes the other thing I need
is chickens chickens chickens chickens
did I miss any chickens over here
there's got to be some stuff that I
missed I don't know how many more
chickens I'm actually gonna need but I
imagine it's gonna be a lot come here no
hey whoa wait hi fight stay away from my
chickens there my head hens I'm gonna
take him on a date with destiny as I
feed him into a giant cat and make it
explode these all sound like they could
be innuendos but trust me they're not
those guys are clamoring around that
thing I wonder if there's X is something
that needs to be addressed up there
probably not stop trying to run away
from your destiny of explosions right
this better be enough I got 11 new
chickens here you look so happy oh oh oh
oh you gave me a heart you love me well
here I am trying to blow you up and you
just want to give me everlasting love
well too bad I need to do something
there's got to be some more chickens
over in this other area maybe oh they're
not happy whoa
why are they not happy is it because
it's war time with the slimes and
there's some serious [ __ ] about to go
down
I mean in slant and slime tax laund town
in slime town there's always something
going on
slime town always have some bad mood you
mood you I can't say words right not
just need more chickens before the
slimes get up uh-oh looks like I was too
late on that order no no no no no no no
no I want the chickens give give give
give give give give Oh God give give
give give give give give with chickens
I'm in the thick of it and this is not
gonna go well
chickadee chick chicks diggity chick
chick Drew's jiggety-jig dicks chick
chick
okay everyone looks very terrified and
for good reason I am in the middle of a
full-scale warrior oh my god
okay off I go ah yeah gross oh god
they're being devoured right out of the
sky who's the other way to go over here
okay I'm gonna get these chickens I
wonder if the big guy has anything to
fear this is gonna be continuing his
life ah about Reuben um oh yeah there's
more there's more honey's over here than
there are rocks so I might as well just
go for the rocks and dammit dammit whoa
boom Rock large oh whoa that's a weird
hybrid cool though honey honey honey
give me a gimme gimme oh good thing I
got a lot of health I've no I don't
think I've ever died except for the time
that I fell off the road are you Oh
briar heads cool I don't know what that
means
I'll take it though lot of ends up here
all right it's good enough for me
eight briar hens lie the other thing la
la la la la la la la la oh hello thank
you needed you
oh hello thank you meeting you oh hello
hey Oh God hello thank you maybe you
you're coming with me you're gonna be so
happy on my farm and even though that it
normally is a euphemism for death and
you know taking someone out in a farm
you're gonna be totally happy imagine
I'm not hundreds incher what are you
mint mango that sounds terrible
I mean no offense to the creator of mint
mango but that is not a flavor
combination that's gonna be agreeable
then oh yes please thank you that's okay
Wow it's an unlimited supply
I guess at night maybe the hens come out
more often that could be cool okay that
probably is gonna be enough so I'm gonna
head back hopefully that big guys still
there and I don't know why I don't have
any slimes that eat meat I've only got
one cat what am I doing with my life
there's oh man this oh god oh god this
is a war Oh oh god what happened to that
one well no watch me eat Oh God
that's a horrible oh I knew it was bad
but I always ran away from it screaming
in fact and wetting my shorts if 28 more
chickens isn't enough to make this cat
explode then I don't know what's gonna
do it and that is a really weird
sentence for me to say but I mean it in
100% sincerity I'm going to blow this
chicken cat away with my chickens and
there's no euphemism to be had anyway
you ready to meet your maker ah Lord
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah clerk flip flip flip flip
flip come on yeah yeah Oh God
Oh you just burst into more cats that's
fine I thought he was gonna burst into
nothingness but that's that's okay I'm
okay with that cuz that means that I can
have some friends from my guys back home
that's super cool and I can go right
home yes it's so perfect
works out 100% perfect they better not
be in my area why do I still hear the
sinister music that ain't good go in
your new home you better not escape I
don't know what maximum capacity is for
this area that's a lot of slimes you
have
yay yay and they've all been said
already goody goody gumdrops are you you
boys off being agreeable here my my
Florrick collector working it's not we
don't know why it's not there it goes
there it goes there it goes give me what
I need give me what I want what I really
really want so tell me what you want
what you really really want whoa okay
the back here sorry about putting you
into the next County money money money
money money I don't know the water we'll
have I seen a water slime yet because
I'm pretty sure I saw stuff in the water
but it didn't know if it was
specifically a water slide are you able
to get out or you can you not make a
stack high enough as I'd like the latter
option to be very true so now I got a
tabby oh look at that they're so
coordinated in trying to escape too bad
for them I have no desire for that to
happen so I need not a feeder over there
and I need an auto collector over here
and I need more rock things to be
perfectly honest your net don't need
that new music box could be nice but I'm
not gonna do that um like I said I'm a
cruel bastard he just doesn't care
okay well there's a lot of chickadees
but I'm gonna wait until morning till
they make some more that way I don't
have to worry about that being all you
know man
and what I'm gonna do next is I'm going
to actually care for my things in the
cave because I haven't seen it forever
and I don't want to be a bad daddy Marga
Blaire is a good daddy yeah this again
with the dad eNOS huh no not exactly
what I'm intending here can I make
upgrades to these things is that
something I can do it is oh it is I'm
gonna make some upgrades to my farms oh
I can't wait it's a nutrient soil
nutrient soils is special ranchers blend
containing compost from the moss Blanc
and minerals from the indigo quarry
crops grown always yield the maximum
harvest sprinklers grow them twice as
fast scarce lime wandering slimes away
from your crops simple but terrifying I
didn't know that was a problem
I guess nutrients soil actually
sprinkler would probably be the best
okay oh look at that
what a waste of water everyone in
California is cringing from the sheer
lack of water that you're producing out
here whoa
okay though my god what is this
sprinkler doing to that tree it's
dancing good night everybody
anybody here one one's not good enough
not good enough at all Shh
you son of a [ __ ] give me your ports
give him to me
what I guess it was only a few hours
since that happened do I got to go out
and manually collect fruit I'm not okay
with this this is not happening I'm very
upset about this I'm gonna go to sleep
again because I'm just gonna sleep
through the night and hope for the best
come tomorrow so good night everybody I
am done with your bowl cuz I need to
deal with my problems in my own way and
the way I choose to do that is sleeping
this treat is feared damn it I slept too
long oh well all right here we go thank
you
all right now these guys just unendingly
eat up all my slit my fruit how am I
supposed to get enough fruit I got
nothing
come on collect come on collect collect
damn it
suck suck like the wind suckling your
nevermind now for dealing with I haven't
you reproduced any make more babies damn
it this is some [ __ ] make more of
you
what other upgrades gonna give to a
chicken coop high walls keep punk
chickens in and hungry slimes out Vitae
miser alright let's do that one since
you guys don't seem to be growing enough
anyway you're going into the feeder
boink boink boink boink boink oops I
guess only one type of chicken survives
here we're gonna we're gonna purge the
normal hen hens and we're gonna only
have Stoney's because apparently I
decided that randomly therefore the
extermination of the hen hens is just a
factor of something happening how much
does this cost
well Rance is very own wild side ah that
would be cool I wouldn't mind going over
there Oh pond cuz I already have the
grotto
so technically my next expansion would
be into the grotto where I would have a
bunch of other types of slimes because
the only time that I don't need is pink
slime that's for gosh darn sure can I
upgrade by bug back sorry yes I need
that yes produced double the fun for 20%
less energy I don't want that so badly I
didn't even realize how much I wanted
that until just now exactly now can you
not feed them feed them damn it need my
floors mine even rocks I'm gonna go to
bed because I'm again I'm very lazy I
could go out and get stuff that I need
but I'm not gonna do that
and I'm just gonna let my life drain
past me as I just wander around
aimlessly ever
[ __ ] rest oh that's the stuff
honey - tree up there Blanca Blanca
Blanca can I hit my target from here
poink yep there we go oh I'm gonna be
rolling in so much money yes and I bet
the cats have something for me too they
are fed weren't they oh yes they were
yeah I got so many ports awesome just
awesome these guys still haven't bred
anymore but that's okay
well buy their time alright shove it in
there oh yes oh yes
rocky ports are still way down at least
everything else is relatively even I got
so much money oh no I'm so many upgrades
it's gonna be amazing cod I love this
this game is oddly pleasing like it's
just something very satisfying about it
and not in the way like you know it's a
farming game in a way but it's a
ranching game moreover and I don't know
if there's a distinct difference and
those look very much like penises I'm
just gonna like no one can disagree that
those look like a bunch of dicks that
are slowly shrinking on the wall like
I'm not it's not even close to a joke
here that is a straight-up dick that is
100% the steadily shrinking shadow of a
giant dick Wow I did not see whoa that
is a hundred-percent penis I'm sorry
whenever I see it that is complimentary
dick and balls - is this intentional
it's just out of this gotta be
intentionally because there is something
very wrong about this site that I'm
seeing right here sorry whenever I see a
dick like my whole brain process just
completely eliminates itself and just
goes into default mode to appreciate
what's happening in front of me and make
as many jokes about it as possible even
though
not clever in any sense these are anyway
okay never mind I gotta go away from
here because I'm being very weird okay
so I need the personal upgrades I'm just
gonna pretend like that never happened
they need the personal upgrades the air
drives yes please
ahh - boots what does hemming have the
energy consumption of sprinting yes oh
my god that's amazing pulse wave and
then our backpack pushes away slimes
whenever you need some personals it
you're cool but I'm gonna get the tank
booster first and then I guess more
power I can only have one oh okay all
right there we go yes oh god I can
sprint forever like a jet pack forever
for twice the fun look at me Oh a
ceiling okay never mind not as much fun
as it once was but you know hey it's
pretty cool okay so that's all for this
episode of slime rancher I've made a lot
of progress even though it's not as
visually appealing as anything else
I've got Auto harvesters on everything
for some reason these are swimming in
carrots uneaten carrots because I don't
think they're eating overfill and then
I've got tons and tons of honey slides
that are never gonna escape
I've got tabby slimes that are happier
now look at them all except for Jeremy
over there is still quite sad they are
hungry so what I need oh that's why
they're crowding the wall because the
chickens over here which I still don't
think I've reproduced at all at any
what's so silly don't do anything for
that oh damn it alright whatever it is
what it is so thank you everybody so
much for watching once again let me know
in the comments below what you want me
to see me do next
my next objective is to find the key
there's got to be another key for that
other wall there that can continue on
unless that's just not an area that's in
the game yet because this is still early
access so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
we do not much appreciate that kind of
behavior around here young lady ma'am